[Music]
we are setting off on a journey fraught
with dangerous notions eternity the
creation of all things from nothing and
dare I add er it a word not to be thrown
around with reckless abandon among those
of Reason infinity a case in point of
the library of Babel it is a library
that holds every book that has ever been
written and every book that ever will be
written now here lies the madness each
book is filled with random strings of
letters 26 letters commas periods spaces
and each book is different but every
volume in every one of these galleries
has four hundred and ten pages each page
has 40 lines each line has 80 letters X
alias that is to nothing but chance so
for every sensible line of
straightforward statement there are
leagues and leagues and leagues of
senseless jumbles and incoherences for
example one volume is made up in its
entirety if the letters M see these
perversely repeated from the very first
lines to the last another is mostly
filled with gibberish until you reach
the next to last page when you see o
time die
[Music]
it is unbearable knowledge that in some
gallery on some shelf a precious cogent
book exists that remains inaccessible
and no one cannot know my belief is the
library stretches - dare I say it the
infinitely many say I'm mistaken that
the possible number of books does have a
limit and while that number is beyond my
understanding
I am gladdened by its distant hope that
however improbable I may one day uncover
something about the library Babel which
is an interesting image for the for the
universe but tonight you're going to
hear for some people who will give you a
much more expansive idea of what reality
is we're going to be talking a lot about
the multiverse tonight and the notion of
infinity and we're also going to address
the question what is what are the
fundamental constituents of nature so
how did we get to this this point in
scientific inquiry into reality let's go
back about 117 years to the year 1900
what did reality consist of what was
physical reality well everyone thought
it was the Milky Way sitting in this
otherwise infinite space it was eternal
and didn't wasn't created would last
forever
how naive that proved to be because in
20 years and 20 years to them about 1920
it was discovered that the universe
couldn't be static it had to be
expanding and we did you know this could
be empirically verified you could see
the galaxies pulling away from us so if
you extrapolate back in time you get
this or origin to everything the Big
Bang so now we have a completely
different view of the universe instead
of it being eternal and Static it had a
finite origin in the past and it might
end in a finite future and a Big Crunch
kind of like human life you're born it's
the Big Bang you die it's the Big Crunch
that's
so completely different view of the
universe and this was actually exciting
to some people a religious sensibility
Pope Pius the 12th when decided when the
Big Bang was discovered you know this is
a scientific proof of creation that the
Big Bang Theory was confirmed in the
1960s when the echo of the Big Bang the
Cosmic Microwave Background
was detected by almost by accident at
first the scientists thought that it was
bird guano on the antenna that was
causing this interference but it turns
out it's the echo of the Big Bang so now
the question is what is this Big Bang
event and in it by the 1970s some guys
that came along two of them are here
fortunately it's really thrilling to
have them here then they came up with
the theory of the Big Bang let's see do
we have images of the two in there in
their 70s hair there they are
not bad for somebody's hair so they they
you know set out to answer the question
you know what is it that bangs why did
it bang and what was going on before it
banged and they came up with a theory
which is called a theory of cosmic
inflation and so now once again there's
a radical shift in our idea of reality
first it was a static finite universe
the Milky Way then it was the BIGBANG
universe it blows up out of nothing in
the seeming creation event and then goes
on its merry history according to the
new theory of inflation our universe is
just you know one member of this vast
perhaps infinite ensemble of universe is
called the multiverse so this is where
we are right now so let me tell you who
these people are first of all where did
our universe come from nobody knows but
our first guests will tell you his name
was Andrei Linde a he is
professor of physics at Stanford our
next guest is the professor of
philosophy at Columbia he's the
Woodbridge professor of philosophy at
Columbia yeah also he has a PhD in
theoretical physics from Rockefeller
University
Daivari David Albert our next guest is a
theoretical physicist and a string
theorist she's one of the founding
members of the Center for quantum
mathematics and physics at the
University of California Davis Veronica
[Music]
our next participant is a professor of
emeritus of applied mathematics at the
University of Capetown investigates
cosmology the nature of time the
emergence of complexity George Ellis our
next guest is is a philosopher of
science he's the only non physicists on
stage but I think if he really had to we
could probably calculate the eigenvalues
of a harmonic oscillator very lower I'm
finally the this is the father of
inflation the man who really first
created in 1979 professor of physics at
MIT professor Guth is famous for saying
the universe is the ultimate free lunch
but on investigation it turns out tax
and tip are not included and you'll hear
out that so anyway these are guests and
let's let's get this thing going we saw
this thing about infinity and we have
somebody on stage the conservative the
more conservative with the more
conservative view of reality which is
Professor Ellis and he believes that
nothing real can have an infinite number
of components so first of all I'm gonna
ask you how do you know that and second
of all are any of you people who are
committed to you a reality that's
infinite in some respect like the
multiverse going to take issue with that
so how do you defend that how do you
know that I'll take a double stand on
this first it for me it's a
philosophical principle and
philosophical principles underlying
science and I'm going with David Hilbert
who said the infinity never occurs in
physical reality and that's because
infinity is beyond what we can ever
attain doesn't matter how many things
you've done how much stuff you've
counted how far you've gone you haven't
taken the first step on the road to
infinity and I think people forget that
when they talk about infinity in loose
ways but more specifically if you claim
there's an infinite number of anything
in the universe galaxies people so it's
an scientifically unprovable because
firstly you can't see them but secondly
if you could see them you could never
prove they were infinite because no
matter how many hundred thousand
million million million million you have
proved you haven't taken the first step
on the way to proving there's infinite
but I believe a scientific statement
should be provable so I think any
statement about science that involves
the word infinity is not provable
therefore it's not science
what if space were infinite and it were
uniform than they were galaxies
uniformly distributed throughout space
do you think that's metaphysically
impossible surely that someone's going
to object to that that was a what if
statement so what if statement yeah well
that might be true but we can see up to
42 million light years away we can't see
anything further so you might say it's
infinite time I say to you no it isn't
it closes up in itself and a finite
radius or I can say that it's bounded by
a singularity of the finite distance you
can't prove you're right I can't prove
I'm right you can say anything you like
I can say anything I'll ah by the way
that's a very controversial statement
because there are many cosmologists now
who believe that our part of the
universe is infinite it's flat and it's
uniformly filled with with matter
including a Brian green I think who's
the father of this whole thing but you
know we have to we have to proponents of
the multiverse here surely you're going
to take issue with this you know rather
metaphysical claim that he's making or
maybe not
[Music]
I'd like to make an important
distinction between what we view is
space and what we view is time space I
think we have no way of knowing directly
whether it's inferred or not as you say
we can only see a certain distance and
only speculate beyond that same thing is
true about time except for time
evolution we kind of have a theory the
Schrodinger equation of quantum
mechanics and quantum mechanics does not
seem to have any natural way of ending
time therefore I think the reasonable
assumption to pursue is that time is
infinite time is the correct statement
is not the time is infinite the correct
step into the time will be infinite in
the far future which we will never reach
because no matter how far time has gone
you haven't reached the far future where
it is infinite so it's always in the
future so it isn't true that it isn't
well
IIIi don't think distinction has any
real importance - I mean space-time
exists we talk about space-time and and
if we know it will exist that's as good
as I don't know what the tenths now
means in the context of a space-time we
need to floss reality we need to it's
very one of the first just a one remark
from theosophy is that Aristotle that
guy a long time ago made a distinction
between the actual infinite and the
potential infinite I think George's view
is that there's a may be a potential
infinity unless there's no boundary
Allan's view might be there's an actual
infinite as far as I can see there's
nothing contradictory about space or
time actually being infinite we know
there are models in mathematics and
which are consistent in which they're
actually in infinitely many abstract
entities at any rate numbers whether any
scientific theory needs to posit the
existence of an actual infinite is a
open question I think get to which is
that given what we call them physics
coma DeLucie tunneling technical word if
you have an infinity of time you
automatically get an infinity of space
coming along with it space and time were
more or less interchangeable in the
context of general relativity pick up on
that I mean science is full of claims
you know current science is committed to
all kinds of claims about what sorts of
laws things are obeying in the Centers
of distant stars that we're never going
to be able to witness but we take it to
be a natural extrapolation of things
that we take ourselves to have good
reason for believing so the observation
which is surely true that there's never
going to be a direct empirical proof
that the world is infinite or that the
world is finite it doesn't seem to me to
be equivalent to a claim like we
couldn't imagine ourselves having what
we take to be good scientific reasons
for supposing that the world is infinite
or finite in this or that respect I'm
Barry just mentioned one
the the you know we have the Schrodinger
equation it's you know we we have all
sorts of good empirical reasons for
having faith in the Schrodinger equation
and the Schrodinger equation doesn't
present this with a natural opportunity
for the time parameter to come to an end
so it seems like a plausible thing to
say that it's infinite you're absolutely
right in pointing out that that's going
to be one among you know uncountable
numbers of claims about the world that
our science is committed to which we're
never going to be able to directly
empirically confirm or refute you seem
to be equated that with a claim that we
couldn't have anything that counts as a
good scientific reason to believe one
way or another about such claims and I
guess I don't see how that follows you
are the father of the theory of eternal
inflation and eternity has a kind of
intimate relationship to infinity give
us your take on this
and make it funny be stopped and that
actually is similar to what actually
happens in our universe most probably
now right now our universe tends to be
well at least started up about 5 billion
years ago exponentially expanding and if
this continues then our part of the
universe eventually will become empty
and we will found ourselves in something
which is called de sitter space and the
sitter space has largest distance from
which we can ever get any information
and this is called de sitter horizon so
the whole universe the whole digital
universe may be infinite but only part
of it will be accessible to us so in a
sense you'll say ok so what is then the
unit multiverse if you have just a
finite patch of everything to explore on
the other hand if we study it a little
bit deeper and study what happens in
string theory for example in string
theory
a lot of different working states in our
working state may decay in the future
and when it decays our horizon may
expand and expand and become infinite or
we may all collapse and die instantly so
there are some possibilities which right
now we cannot even fully first see all
of this picture of the universe didn't
exist in the sense which we perceive it
right now it didn't exist about 35 years
ago so to come and stay I would forbid
this picture being discussed because it
well against my general principle this
would probably be well III would warn us
against following the lead of those who
want to forbid us something but I don't
think that George want to forbid he want
to put a question mark here be careful
because there is something we should be
taken into account seriously and I
absolutely agree with this position
I particularly want to put a question
mark against statements coming out in
the popular journals saying how far away
is your next self and I just think to
talk about yourself having infinite
replications is kind of really
stretching beyond this notion of the
universe there are exact replicas 10 to
the 10 to the 100 you know angstroms or
light-years it doesn't matter that scale
away careful with words because
multiverse is used like a slogan by many
and if you try to Google the multiverse
who studies it how the tendency then she
grows up all the time and then you will
do more careful search who actually will
dialing on Google the multiverse it
appears that most of the people who do
it are from Peru and then next position
is from France
and then you will fine-tune the search
and it appears that people in Peru they
playing the game dragon multiverse
so what kind of game do we play and this
is actually very very simple just think
about our own earth there are many many
countries on earth each country has its
own laws okay
China Russia us and then imagine that
the size of the universe blows up to
incredible ball size and that the main
idea of inflation so we have China so
large that anybody living in China would
have no idea about United States in the
United States would not have any trade
war with China because it will be not
infinitely but practically infinite
distance and there will be no internet
connection or whatever so then the this
is a very simple very practical idea and
then somebody comes and say oh I live in
the place where these set of laws and
this set of laws is unique and other
laws are impossible and if I water than
its liquid water and the captain of the
ship just take the ship and then
suddenly in night he crashes into solid
water and Titanic goes down so the fact
that we have seen something experienced
something it does not necessarily prove
that something else is not possible and
broad a set of possibilities as a larger
set of rules is more natural from my
perspective than forbidding something
beforehand I'm trying to bring Veronica
into this but I do want to bring you in
prematurely would you as a string
theorist and of course the string theory
feeds into the idea of the inflationary
multiverse because it produces something
called a landscape multiverse but you
have a slightly coy and cagey
relationship to string theory because
you see it more as a tool rather than as
a fun a real description of reality but
I'm I'll let you talk I mean I view it
as a framework which allows all these
possibilities depending on what you put
in so it doesn't really bother me that
the framework allows
all these possibilities and whether or
not there's infinitely many of them you
know doesn't threaten our our notion of
reality and and and so forth but let me
put in a word for infinity in a context
of dust can infinity be useful in
physics so so far we have been talking
about you know is our universe infinite
or something like that and I I
sympathize with all that have been sort
of said on stage here that you know if
you count physical objects let's say
then of course you can never get
infinitely many of them but you know if
you it might still be mathematically
useful notion in the sense that if you
allow me that that can be say zero
number of a certain types of objects
then I can just say well let me talk
about one over that okay that's that's a
bit silly example but it it goes to sort
of it's meant to illustrate that there
could be different descriptions of the
same physical reality and those
different descriptions could be useful
for various different things and it
could be that in one of these
descriptions the thing that's most
natural is the one over the what end
that ends up being zero I think this is
a very important point I think just as
infinity doesn't exist in physics zero
doesn't exist in physics either and
that's what the quantum vacuum tells us
so I don't believe that I don't believe
that between my fingers there's an
infinite number uncountably infinite
number of physically different points
and that's equivalent to saying that
those points have zero size in fact in
in in the real universe I believe that
space time must be quantized will have a
little finite size and then there won't
be an infinite number of points between
my fingers two things I wanted to add to
this conversation one was about what
Veronica just said in this discussion
with George and that is if you can count
to infinity if it took half as long to
count the next thing is it did the
previous thing then of course that would
be a series that converges to infinity
sure though George thinks that that's an
impossibility the other thing that I
count to infinity you say it takes you
one second to say 1 1/2 a second say to
a quarter of a second say 3 and so
you've run through all the numbers in 2
seconds that way other thing I noticed
was the different attitudes that Andrei
and George have to what exists Andrei's
idea if it said if it's not forbidden
it's there
George is you got to show me it's there
that it's it's there only if it's and
demonstrated to be their position minds
of physics given what I know about
Andres background in physics is
shorthand for waste of time two years
from Russia and one of my friends there
well expressed his attitude of the
difference between how things work in
different countries and he say in Russia
everything that it is not explicitly
allowed is forbidden in the United
States everything that it is not
explicitly forbidden is allowed and I
much prefer this was possibility
so I think that's really very good in
politics maybe not so good in
epistemology so we've done infinity and
eternity now so let's move on to
something I mean how about creation now
Andre and Allan but had both years ago
had a kind of really clever creation ex
nihilo scheme and I understood it and I
thought I don't know whether it's true
or not but it's a an alternative to you
know the God bringing the world into
existence and all of that and the idea
was that out of sheer nothing a little
nugget of false vacuum could quantum
tunnel into existence that white sure
nothing they need something very
particular it's a closed space time of
zero radius so it's like taking a
balloon and shrinking down to a point
and that's the closest you can get
mathematically speaking to defining
nothingness so out of this beginning of
nothing a little nugget of false vacuum
quantum tunnels into existence and then
by the magic of inflation this blows up
into the multiverse but now everyone has
stopped believing in it and you believe
that the universe the multiverse didn't
have a an origin in a finite time in the
past
it's eternal looking back into the past
and eternal looking into the future and
you know I frankly don't understand this
why were you wrong about saying it had a
finite past in the first place Allan you
had a proof of mathematical proof that
the universe had a finite beginning in
the in the past and now yet what was
wrong with proof listen why should we
bleed you on global warming if you okay
kidding nothing was wrong with the proof
with what's wrong is your summary of the
argument
[Laughter]
the statement was never that the
universe necessarily had a beginning the
statement is that we followed the era of
inflation backwards the era of inflation
had to have a beginning that we still
think is true and it's certainly also
but I think you exaggerated tremendously
when you said that now all of you people
don't believe that the universe had a
beginning as far as I know I'm really
just speaking here for myself and Sean
Carroll we've been working together on a
model of the universe that would be
eternal and in this model that Sean and
I are working on it will was originally
proposed by Sean to give credit where
credit is due
we'd be living in an era where time is
going forward and entropy that is
disorder which we think of as almost a
proxy for what the finds the arrow of
time disorder is growing towards the
future
and getting smaller towards the past and
then these models with a definite
beginning the universe would have begun
at some finite time in the past with
essentially zero entropy zero disorder
and that's still a possibility I don't
mean to say that that's not possible
what appeals to Sean me about this
alternative approach has to do with the
symmetry in physics symmetry of time
reversal invariance all the laws of
physics that we know of our time
reversal invariant that is we here can
be sitting on the stage and talking and
time has gone forward if there's also a
quantum state wherever all that is
reversed then everything is happening
exactly the same but in the opposite
order the laws of physics don't care
about distinctions between future and
past and one puts in a beginning of this
sort you're putting in a distinction
between the future in the past we have a
beginning in the past the goal is to
produce a picture of the universe or
multiverse where know where those when
put in anything that violates this
symmetry between future and past so the
way the model works there's an
intermediate period which you might
think of is the logical starting point
where the arrow of time is not
well-defined disorder might be growing
might be shrinking doing one thing one
place one thing a different place just
chaos basically but then if you follow
that forward in time
there are laws that we think we
understand which say that
disorder will start to grow entropy will
grow an hour of time will develop going
that way and we also have in mind that
all this is going to be undergoing in
inflation and in fact eternal inflation
if you follow the same thing backwards
in time the same thing happens but in
the opposite order of this the laws of
physics as I mentioned don't care about
T vs minus T so if you follow up
backwards in time
entropy disorder starts to go in that
direction inflation happens backwards in
that direction so you have this
two-headed arrow of time picture and the
beauty of that is the full system is is
completely time reversal invariant zoom
same thing back so you have a nice
picture of the multiverse which
automatically contains an arrow of time
which was not put in by hand but arises
naturally just from the evolution of
laws of physics that we think we already
understand David you're the natural
person to critique this because you you
this is the man who coined the term the
past hypothesis which a very simple
coinage but is really caught on the past
hypothesis explain with the past
although I don't think it's in such
dramatic conflict with this the usually
before we were considering theories of
the kind that we're just described we
used to we used to think that we needed
to make a special posit to the effect
that that there was a initial state of
the universe where the entropy was very
low what's going on in in Sean's
proposal is is that the idea is being
floated that maybe the cosmos doesn't
have anything like an equilibrium
condition that is the cosmos there isn't
any upper bound to the entropy that that
the cosmos can have so so wherever you
start out entropy is going to go up from
both sides of that it doesn't matter
what kind of state that is that's still
going to be that's still going to be a
situation in which on either side of
this minimum
you have the equivalent of a past
hypothesis
you're just not you're not claiming that
that things can't be and you know that
things can't be traced back even behind
that so this seems to me not something
not something that contradicts the past
hypothesis it's an it's an attempt to
put something like a past hypothesis in
a larger framework well you know at the
moment there's this huge controversy
over the over inflationary theories in
the multiverse you know we have the - -
of the creators of the theory of cosmic
inflation here on stage when the third
arguably the third father of the theory
inflation is Paul Steinhardt who's the
Albert Einstein professor of physics at
Princeton and he's now become an
adversary of the of the theory of
inflation and there in the Scientific
American I believe there was an article
published by Steinhardt and some
collaborator hydrators arguing that the
theory of inflation was a bit of a
failed research paradigm tell us why
there's so much suspicion about the
theory of inflation among you know
pertinent perfectly reputable physicists
Barry you you good Barry's a good friend
of Steinhart so he can give the I know
Steinhardt now the others about but I'm
not a party to that because I'm not a
cosmologists but it does remind me of a
famous remark that Lev Landau famous
physicist Russian physicists made about
cosmologists I think the rim barkos
something like this cosmologists often
an error never in doubt that's good oh I
think all cosmologists you must be
taught this in the very beginning that
wasn't even your to explain to us why
why they're unhappy I mean it's there
are two reasons as far as I understand
it there are our intrinsic problems with
the theory of inflation it's in a way
it's too elastic there are too many
versions of their hundreds of proposals
for a theory of inflation and they all
hypothesize a field that does just what
you want the field to do and there's no
empirical evidence that this field
exists and the other problem is that it
implies the existence
a multiverse in which anything that can
happen will happen so how do you test
them thing so that's a very cool three
reasons I don't think that I think
there's reasons to think that the kinds
of fields responsible for inflation
could exist and so I don't think that
that's their objection so much but I do
think that their objections that are
interesting to philosophers that you
mentioned one is that as I think you
mentioned earlier inflation was
introduced in order to explain certain
things about the initial initial
conditions in the early universe like
that the universe has a very flat
geometry that the universe is very
homogeneous and these need to be put in
by hand in the Big Bang account without
inflation inflation looked as though it
was giving an explanation of this would
look like fine-tuning but their worry is
and also Roger Penrose is worried is
that more fine-tuning is really needed
to get inflation going in the first
place that's one worry another is that
inflation is really a whole model a big
framework of theories with a lot of free
parameters in them and by changing the
values that parameters the the the
potential energy of the field and the
curve of the field and so on you can get
it to adjust various empirical
consequences and that that objections
seems that somewhat at odds with their
other main and very interesting to a
philosopher objection and that is if
inflation is generically leads to
internal inflation the production of all
of these pocket universes and if in
these pocket universes can be very
different maybe even fill up the whole
landscape of string theory as I think
some people think then it looks like the
theory itself is predicting that
anything that can happen will happen as
Allen has been quoted is as saying and
it looks as though a theory like that
just can't have empirical evidence for
it and that's a really interesting issue
to hash through maybe a little bit too
in a house for here I don't know but
it's so I want to give you an idea of
the the
different proposals of poor periods of
inflation yours verse you used the term
inflation first to refer to this
cosmological theory then you came up
with chaotic inflation which became
internally eternal inflation Steinhardt
was extended inflation and then we have
we have also extended I should double
inflation triple inflation hybrid
inflation mutated hybrid inflation
tilted hybrid inflation hyper extended
placeand
and invariably super natural inflation
and that's just that there are hundreds
of others not all of which have names
I'm sorry I'm not first because there
are much more okay but what is important
about them that all of them are just
versions of one general principle and
this principle is that in the very
beginning of the universe for whatever
reasons and we can speculate whether it
was tunneling from nothing as Alex
Vilenkin suggested or some features of
wave function of the universe or
whatever the region of space tiny tiny
region of space filled with some special
kind of matter which is not very
specific and then the space if you
follow equations of motion which anybody
can solve it's really really simple
start expanding exponentially and then
after that it produces big chunk of
space which is much bigger than people
expected before and after that decaying
field produce all matter in the universe
and it looks like science fiction you
solve equation you see that's how it is
so that's a basic principle
after that you start fine-tuning
what if I need to adjust some parameters
of the theory to describe whatever they
the experimenters are going to bring us
and what if I try to implement it in
string theory supergravity grant in fact
theory that's why many people's is just
that many different versions they based
on the same principle now let's compare
with the history of standard model of
elementary particle physics describing
weak strong and electromagnetic
interactions just in describing
weak and electromagnetic interactions
required 20 parameters to adjust the
theory to describe experimental data
marzo the Higgs boson very large nobody
could predicted mass of the top quark
very large but people knew that top
quark is necessary so what is necessary
to achieve is some framework and then
feed the data at the moment there are
some inflationary models which require
just a single parameter to describe all
inflation related data which Planck
satellite and other experiments given
one parameter is enough is it
complicated
I don't think so look here's something
that people may be puzzled about one
here's two claims about inflation as
it's practiced now one that there is
spectacular enormous ly impressive
agreement between its predictions and
what we see second that it's a theory
that predicts that everything that can
happen will okay and will for certain
and there's prima facie an obvious
puzzle about how to put these two
remarks together with one another if you
know go back to your analogy of the
earth expanding there are all these
different countries they have different
laws there an infinite number of them in
fact they have very very different laws
things are very different going from one
country to another somebody's about to
open his eyes and would like information
from science about what he should expect
to see okay it seems like if you have if
you have a situation that the picture of
the world is there's this enormous earth
on which there an infinite number of
places and everything describable is
happening in one or another of those
places this is going to give the person
exactly zero information about what he
should expect to see and in this case it
seems puzzling good so this is but
presumably you understand
puzzlement yeah and good okay you want
answer this but since I'm the one who
keeps getting quoted saying that in the
multiverse anything that can happen will
happen an infinite number of times even
let me just clarify that sentence if
something has a probability of ten to
the minus six it means if you do
something five times it's very unlikely
to happen if you do it ten to the six
times it's likely to happen once if you
do it an infinite number of times it's
likely to happen has to happen in fact
an infinite number of times but the
probability is still ten to the minus
one-sixth if you do only make a finite
number of observations the probability
of you seeing that is very small as I
like to say even if there is a
multiverse unfortunately the probability
of my winning the lottery tomorrow is
not high it remains not but let me just
jump in there okay go ahead what you're
saying implies that the picture comes
along with some set of probabilities of
this being the world that's realized or
that being the word that's realized and
my understanding of the current status
of the theory in which people are
looking for a so-called measure over
these worlds which would provide us with
the with the probability you're talking
about is is an element of the theory
which is so far not in place okay which
we're hoping is going to be in place and
is going to give us the right
probabilities is going to identify what
we see as a high probability kind of an
event would somebody be wrong to say oh
I see so the hard part hasn't even begun
yet okay all of the physics of this is
going to rest in the choice of a measure
that part that's a notion of uncertainty
onto which we haven't even dipped or
into which we haven't even dipped our
toes yet would that be a fair thing to
say I think I'll be a slight
exaggeration I mean I said no a lot of
what Dave Dave just said is true
there is a measure problem and I was
just gonna get there honestly whenever
physicists talk about the measure
problem they're talking about a
fiendishly difficult problem having to
do with defining probabilities when you
have you know in an infinite number of
you know possible events and it's all
physicists say you know tend to skirt it
they tend to because it does seem to be
all insoluble in every context in which
it arises but so the measure of problem
means a problem with defining
probabilities that's that's all yeah
vacation so people work on inflationary
cosmology are aware of this major
problem when we say it's an unsolved
problem I don't know it's either an
unsolved problem or a problem for which
we have multiple solutions those are
kind of equivalent statements more or
less we don't yet know what the right
solution is we certainly do have
proposals which define probabilities and
ways which seem to be perfectly
consistent with everything that we know
of so we think of this decision of how
to define a measure as an empirical
decision we do have ways which work
empirically I should also emphasize that
there's no doubt that it's possible to
define probabilities on infinite spaces
mathematicians will be doing that for
ages for a century anyway so the only
quit is their many choices usually and
that's the issue here so we do have to
find the right choice but there doesn't
seem to be any problem in finding
choices that are very sensible what we
still need and hope to find is a way of
definitively determining what the right
measure okay look let's get away from
the measure problem it's just too hard
and let's get on something simple like
anti-de sitter space conformal field
theory duality and the holographic
principle which you have to talk about
because we haven't heard enough from you
you have two interesting takes on the
fundamental nature reality so in in
string theory we have seen these
remarkable statements which we refer to
as dualities which is the interesting
situation that the same physics is
described by different theories
different mathematical languages if you
will and so there isn't a sensible way
to ask the question which one is correct
they are they're both correct
in this particular example of duality
which is referred to as a DSC Ft duality
or
gauge gravity duality the two sides that
describe the same physics are a theory
of gravity in particular string theory
okay living in higher dimensions which
is precisely equivalent to a theory
without gravity a so called gauge the
conformal field theory living in lower
dimensions in fact you can think of it
as living on the boundary of the
space-time that the gravity lives in and
well it is believed more generally more
generally so studying black holes that
any theory of gravity has this
holographic nature to it that you can
encode all the information that's
happening in such a theory with a lower
dimensional to it if you could only see
the shadows on the wall
you couldn't reconstruct everything that
was going on at the cocktail party in
the room right with shadows indeed you
couldn't tell enough neither can we tell
with movies which seemed a little bit
better than shadows and yet they are
supposed to be you know two-dimensional
representations of our three-dimensional
world because you don't see what's
behind that you know foreground things
or stuff like that so here in this
holographic duality we would have you
know clever shadows er things that
actually know the entire sea okay so
indeed that's very counterintuitive you
fit all this information on a lower
dimensional theory but maybe the point
to make is that a theory of gravity
already does not have as much room in it
as you might have thought and that is
the reason for that is is gravity in
once you have gravity you can collapse
black holes for example which is a very
generic type of behavior and if you try
to say pack in as much information as
you can
in a given region say in this room okay
now we can think you bring your book and
we can read it in that some amount of
information I bring another book and the
great brings one more book and so forth
and we can pack this room with books and
that's still there's no problem with
that but once we sort of tried to
packing so many books that we would sort
of push at the limit of how much
information can be packed in gravity
takes over and the whole thing will
collapse into a black hole and now we'll
see that in fact the amount of
information scales only with sort of the
surface area of this room rather than
with a volume okay so gravity has
somehow built in the structure of having
being describable by a lower dimensional
sea okay so that's called the
holographic principle now this duality
is a concrete realization of that this
so-called EDS CFT duality the ATS side
is stands for anti-de sitter it's a
particular space-time that has a
negative cosmological constant so very
different from the expanding universe
that we're living in but nevertheless
because it's a theory of gravity it
contains black holes and in fact we
believe that black holes are behave just
like the black holes that you know we
see out in our in our universe and now
the miracle is that yes there is this
other description this lower dimensional
description that now does not have
gravity it does not have black holes but
everything that sort of is happening
around us all these black holes and
stuff like that are described in this
completely different language it's very
square but it's a same same physics is
happening in this in the bulk theory in
the higher dimensional theory you've got
a black hole in the boundary theory
which is a complete description as well
the what looks like a black hole is
actually a bath of gluons and quarks so
David being a philosopher is concerned
with reality as it is in itself he wants
to know which is real
they're black holes or maybe that's a
naive question I'm being forced to say
something that I don't that I'm not sure
I believe I mean I guess there is maybe
here's a way to put the question look
physics has tons of mathematical
equivalences so we can talk about say
the the condition of a classical system
of particles portrayed in
three-dimensional space or we can talk
about it in configuration space or we
can talk about it in phase space all of
these are in a very straightforward
sense mathematically equivalent mapable
into each other
isomorphic to each other there is a
temptation to say in the classical case
yes but notwithstanding these
isomorphisms the three-dimensional space
is the real one the three-dimensional
space is the physical one is there an
analogous question in the kinds of
equivalence is that you're talking well
there may be several things one could
say about this maybe you think even in
the classical case the question doesn't
make sense
well although most people would think it
does I think there's a you know hidden
assumption in this which is who is
asking okay so you are asking and you
are sort of local object and to use
talking in sort of the position space
it's most natural so then that somehow
singles out a preferred description
because in some sense you're sort of
providing the basis on which to ask this
question but what is it I don't
understand how I'm I'm part of this
description - there's an old question
attributed to Vidkun Stein people said
to him people said to him you know he
said I can't understand why
I the the Copernican theory was
counterintuitive and people said well
because it looks like the earth goes it
looks like the Sun goes around the earth
and Vic and Stein
no but Vic and Stein reportedly said
what would it look like if it looked
like the earth goes around the Sun and
so I take it the same question applies
here so is the claim sure if I prefer to
describe things in 3-dimensional space
of course I'll be describing them in
3-dimensional space if there's some
psychological feature of me which
prefers three-dimensional space of
course I'll describe them in three
dimensions most people would say and it
sounds like you think the you think the
right thing to say about this is just
that it's a mistake most people would
say in classical mechanics no there's
some metaphysically significant sense in
which the physical space is
three-dimensional and in which the
others and in which the others are just
sort of abstract mathematical
representations you think in the
classical is that if your brain is
flashed on the wall right thing good
exactly right but your brain is a blast
on the wall according to but that is the
same brain is the one that's in the
three dimensional space I think those
are two things aren't they the same
thing good if they're the same thing
then
it's a linguistic question right we have
different descriptions of the same thing
and that thing is you know there is one
thing but we're describing them in
different languages and now you're sort
of trying to force me to say well isn't
one preferred to the other because we
somehow have this gut feeling that yes
we are living again I'm not trying to
force you to say anything that the but
it's just a question in the simple
classical case most people would say
indeed this is how people are taught
physics oh I see what's going on the
real deal is three-dimensional space and
there are particles moving around in
three-dimensional space there are
various other abstract mathematical
representations which are useful in
certain contexts configuration space
phase space so on and so forth
these are useful there are all kinds of
problems where I'm going to turn to
those but there's some sense in which
I'm going to think what's really going
on is the three-dimensional space with
the particles moving around in it and
and it's not that I'm claiming that's
obviously right it's interesting that
that's what most people even people with
a physics education would tend to say
it's convenient and it's convenient
psychologically but why is it crucial
because somebody wants to know what's
the dimensionality of space and and it
sounds to them David what's your answer
to that by the way yeah very
counterintuitive answer yeah that's
another story
okay just tell me how many dimensions
space n times the number of well the
number of elementary degrees of freedom
yeah so what's the order of magnitude is
it about it's it's really big
yeah so we have 12 minutes left and the
two topics I thought were interesting
were you're getting onto the soft ones
beauty is a guide to truth in physics
that maybe - but but but George is
interested in the limits of physics and
the limits of science and if we knew the
universal wavefunction could we predict
that the
we were gonna get together and have this
particular conversation and say these
particular things does it leave any room
for free will this and you have a notion
of top-down causation which I'm very
skeptical of but I want to hear about it
I want to be free will is a difficult
one but let me make the following
statement according to the standard big
bank till it's heaven period of
inflation I'm happy with that we've got
the last scattering surface we matter
and radiation decouple we've got
particles on the last scattering so it
was a question of the following if we
knew everything about the last
scattering service to the finest detail
could we predict what is happening in
this room at this moment could we
predict physically what you have just
said my claim is absolutely not there
isn't the faintest chance that would be
true the reason is because for many many
reasons
I'll just take two when this quantum
uncertainty between here and there and I
could amplify on it the second one is
that what what coin of what because
knowledge do is they characterize
something called the transfer function
which goes from here to here we have
difficulty even explaining a black hole
dark halos and so on we have difficulty
characterizing the distribution of
galaxies in practical terms is not the
faintest chance but supposing there was
a chance of doing that then you would be
telling me that somehow the words you've
just said we're written into the last
scattering surface by some Demiurge and
I don't happen to believe that that
could possibly have happen
so the real statement is the last
scattering surface set up the conditions
whereby higher level beings like you and
me could come into being where we have
psychological powers in which we can
argue at a psychological level and that
psychological level has real causal
powers which are allowed by the physics
but they are not predicated by the
physics the physics cannot tell you what
you are going to say in psychological
terms because you're doing a logical
argument and the physics has no concept
what that logical argument is and which
you said is a highly heterodox point of
view and does anyone here agree with
that does anyone here because it seems
to violate the unitarity of quantum
mechanics and I believe quantum
mechanics is unitary because I happen to
believe that mission
take place every time my measurement
takes place is not unity sorry I don't
know I don't understand what any quantum
physicist says quantum mechanics is
unitary so do you think this is
important because it does leave a note
London opening to a robust notion of
free will yep okay and surely this must
have raised some hackles here these are
excessively polite people but they're
raging inside I would like to get one
clarification from suckage about what
what a measurement is in your view so
weather measurements before there were
people and quantum measurement problem
we're getting into which is really
measurement is coming because people
first discovered this in laboratories
but a measurement takes place where in a
superposition goes to an eigenfunction
that's a non unitary process because you
lose the information about the
superposition and you end up with one
specific that happens all the time
everywhere it happened in the early
universe where nuclear synthesis took
place long before there was a when does
it what are the well it's the law that
determines when that happens we do not
know that's one of the big things we
don't know how it happens and we have no
specific characterization or when it
happens is one of the biggest Kuna the
foundations of quantum mechanics yeah
those pictures of the screen with the
particles coming on to the screen and
you cannot predict where the next
particle come on those wonderful
pictures the particles come on one by
one nobody can predict where the next
one come but eventually you put up those
it builds up to those interaction
patterns in which you can predict with
great fidelity what the final
statistical thing will be but you cannot
predict what the next one will be and
that is the evidence for what I've just
been says that consistent with the
average interpretation or many other
interpretations of our mechanics that do
not invoke this mysterious giveaway
function give me some way of
experimentally showing the Everitt
interpretation is true just weak so look
as Jim said we're getting here into
altogether different territory of the
measurement problem in quantum mechanics
but we now have lots of ways of thinking
about the measurement
it's too early to know just as with
choosing between inflationary theories
it's too early to know which if any of
the ones we have now is going to turn
out to be correct but but we have lots
of ways of thinking about them which
contradict crucial assumptions that you
were making on our us supporting the
Everest interpretation which is putting
no I'm not I'm not actually I'm a I'm a
very I'm a very trenchant critic of the
Everett interpretations no one uses the
term ever ideas in any world they're
three of three or four interpretations
they're all good so there is this puzzle
[Music]
if we come back to my question I think
Ellen and says there's ilion's of other
worlds out there in which we each said
different things rather than what we
actually sit here I think it is simpler
makes more sense to say the Grail
emergence takes place in which we do
have real psychological powers and in
which we can make logical arguments came
to logical conclusions lead to what we
say and I think that is what has happens
not that there's a zillions of other
possible things happening out there
which we cannot prove how happening okay
I would say nobody on stage agrees with
that but actually the whole discussion
brings us a little bit back to discussed
and that is about the measure problem
because right now we're returning to the
measurement problem which is a different
problem which is however very much
related because in both cases were
talking about whether there was
something in the early universe which
was definitely defined before anybody
have seen it because the measure problem
is what is the problem over the first
event which now nobody have seen it then
the wave function was not reduced and
stuff like that so what is interesting
about that is the measurement problem is
discussed by everyone for almost a
hundred years and you can really find
people who are complete
in all details agree about the solution
of this measurement problem and
nevertheless quantum mechanics works
pretty well everywhere agree about that
so I think that this is very similar to
what happens with inflationary cosmology
which we do there are not so many people
who absolutely agree about which
probability measure in in world many
world
while many universe interpretation of
inflationary theory is better but what
more or less everybody agrees among
experimentalists with whom we're
discussing it who are providing us with
data so more or less everybody agrees
that if you have a given inflationary
theory
it gives them predictions which they
check and the checking so far was pretty
successful let me take a simpler example
we've come into existence through
Darwinian evolution now my claim is the
following Darwinian evolution is
consistent with physics but it is not
implied by physics there is no physics
textbook in which you will read the
chapter on Darwinian even because it
isn't a physics result it's a biology
result couple of things I mean one thing
that's striking is that people could
come away from here learning that there
are two big issues in the philosophical
foundations of physics that are on the
table the measurement problem is Andrews
saying the measurement problem old one
in the foundations of quantum mechanics
and the measure problem a newer one was
important difference in the two cases in
the case of the measurement problem
there's quantum mechanics everyone
learns or takes physics learns how to
use it to make predictions in the
experiments that they do what they
disagree with is what's really going on
when measurements are being made what
the reality Iying reality is George has
one view David may have another view and
I have another view in the case of the
measure problem it's a problem that
arises for a particular theory in
cosmology the theory of inflation and
it's really a question of whether or not
the theory itself makes any predictions
at all until the measure problem is
actually solved so these are two rather
different
both very important and interesting
issues we have three minutes left on the
notion of beauty beauty very fuzzy
notion but people great physicists like
Stephen Weinberg
the father of the standard model says
that you know we're now in an era where
we don't have a lot of experimental data
and observational data that we've
reached the limits of the you know there
won't be a bigger particle accelerator
than the Large Hadron Collider built in
the foreseeable future we're sort of up
against an empirical wall and when that
happens physicists rely on their sense
of beauty and beauty has been a very
reliable guide to truth Weinberg said
when he was a graduate student at
Harvard Paul Dirac came and said to the
graduate students don't pay attention to
what your equations mean just pay
attention to how beautiful they are and
and this is a kind of a weirdly mystical
Lotus eating notion but beauty has
proved to be a reliable guide to truth
in the past and now we were in a
situation where theories like string
theory which were thought to be
beautiful initially are now looking
rather ugly and people would make the
same claim about inflation but I I will
name them because I did Sheldon Glashow
he said it's like metal he said it's
like medieval Sheldon Glashow in 71
suggested he is alternative to the
standard model of electromagnetic
interactions standard model was based on
the theory sorry for math su 2 cross you
want two different groups two different
coupling constants many particles
anomalies doesn't work and he suggested
his own beautiful mostly symmetric model
vector model no anomalies everything is
great and everybody sir oh yeah
electroweak theory one Uppsala model no
it's that because it is not beautiful
and Shelley glacial model is so
beautiful and then they discovered
neutral currents and they're very shaded
glacial model okay he got his Nobel
Prize but the one vessel our model
survived
so that's how it was Eddie got a
character named after about the Big Bang
theory the TV show right do you have one
no there's no Andre there's a shelter
anyone else have anything to say on any
epigrammatic observations to make on
beauty is a guide to truth and it's just
two facts yeah well first of all I would
dispute that string theory is not
beautiful but that's that's me but but I
think okay the the word beauty has all
these other meanings
I would I would think simplicity and
internal consistency are much more
descriptive and certain types of logical
rigidity and the example of that was
general relativity you alter it a little
bit it crashes whereas string theory is
very elastic no no well you might be I
mean it has that the internal
consistency is very powerful tool in
fact it's very restrictive and of I mean
it's clear to all of us that whatever we
propose as a theory can't be neutrally
you know self inconsistent and but you
might think that that's a useless thing
because you know just about anything you
propose you can fiddle around with to
make it self consistent but that doesn't
happen and so this takes us much further
along than than one might have thought
and it turns out I mean the physics
packages itself in some nice way and
yeah it's this here predicts multiverse
so it was really beautiful
but yeah okay so we've heard we've come
to the end we've heard the we've heard a
scientific account of the universe and
we've heard the philosophers commenting
on it so I think we should just give the
last word to religion so the religious
story is in the beginning there was
nothing and God said let there be light
and there was still nothing but now you
could see it and then I have to say
thank you again everyone
[Music]
you
[Music]